there is a mental model called inversion
according to inversion when we face a
daunting conundrum the most pertinent
course of action is to think backwards
namely by going back to the fundamentals
of the issue and trying to deconstruct
its main constituents we end up
increasing the chances of solving it or
at least decreasing the chances of
allowing it to inflict misery upon us
inversion despite its very useful nature
is an arcane term for most people most
people ignore inversion and they do so
in a very irresponsible fashion we
firmly believe that the best way to
solve a problem is just by capitalizing
on conventional wisdom and preconceived
notions they cling to save parents that
they feel a custom to and they repeat
these patterns perpetually without
questioning or without the willingness
to test something more innovative the
origins of this behavior are
multifarious
for starters we have the path of least
resistance this has its origins in
physics where it is used as a heuristic
that describes the approximation of the
tendency to the least energy state in
colloquial language we use it to allude
to the proclivity of humans to avoid
personal effort or confrontation then we
have the notions of ego and identity
when a person is faced with a situation
that silence is the essence of their
identity that is the substrate of their
belief system the mere thought of
challenging this belief system convulses
the backbone of their being finally we
need to deal with the unbearable
struggle entailed in every aspect of the
fabric of the societies we have created
humans weren't ready to face the
ramifications of being prime of beings
in technologically evolved world despite
the fact that living conditions keep
improving and wellness indexes keep
rising
psychologically humans aren't doing well
many philosophers and psychologists have
attempted to shed light on the ways to
deal with this predicament with Jung
being the one that has offered the most
intriguing one every person has a shadow
that is comprised of the darkest facets
of one's character and the way to battle
and eventually control the shadow is to
encourage the emergence of the heroic
element within our psyche unfortunately
not all of us can embrace the heroic
effect of our personality and thus we
end up in a perennial state of struggle
and grievance as you can imagine it
takes a combination of courage emotional
resilience and tenacity to be ready to
navigate within this complex
construction that we have assembled and
the interesting part is that due to
entropy and u2r proclivity towards
growth complexity increases
exponentially there is no way to avoid
that and for better or for worse the
best idea is to make peace with
complexity in order to alleviate the
frustration that it causes the word
complexity originates from the word
complex which means composed of
interconnected parts the reason I use
the etymology of the word complexity is
to allow awareness to grow through
understanding I have always been a huge
proponent of the system's thinking
philosophy and one of my strongest
beliefs has always been that confusion
is a result of a lack of integration of
parts within thinking systems we become
confused because something is missing or
because something doesn't feel right the
composition of interconnected parts that
gives rise complexity is not in tune
with our awareness and as a result the
melody of our world becomes distorted
humans don't like distortion or at least
were not programmed to like it our role
is to become masters of our part of the
world and orchestrate the right
composition through an elaborate process
of wise selection of distinct elements
we can really become masters of the
whole world because the whole world is
beyond our scope of understanding and
the composition becomes too vast when
the composition becomes too vast it
feels like a Mis mass of chaotic
elements and we end up floating in an
ocean of far-fetched possibilities and
opportunities nobody likes to float
aimlessly nobody likes to feel lost
this somewhat lengthy but necessary
introduction served as a prelude to the
challenging question what should I do
with my life
this is a question so common but at the
same time so important that I don't
really know how to handle it whenever I
need to face it it is strongly related
to complexity and one cannot go about
answering it without showcasing a rather
basic understanding of how complexity
affects almost every decision we have to
make the what should I do with my life
question arises usually when complexity
has overwhelmed individual to such a
degree that decision-making becomes
quite arduous even for the simplest
events in life the amount of external
stimuli that increases exponentially
through technology and through social
networks affects our possibilities and
also our desires when we are
interconnected with so many agents
around the world we feel that we want
everything even if we don't really
possess the capacity to imagine what
everything would feel like I guess
that's why everyone is so enamored with
the idea of parallel universes we want
so many things that only multiple
interconnected versions of ourselves can
offer that luxury in this perilous
landscape most of us fail to recognize
one paramount detail about human nature
we're quite valuable creatures and it is
this value bility that we need to reduce
in order to make our experience more
tolerable and eventually come up with
suggestions decisions when it comes to
what should I do with my life
in this current point in time two seem
to be the most pertinent rules we need
to follow in order to reduce variability
to pick our battles wisely and to
embrace slowness
when it comes to struggle you need to be
ready to fight it you need to be ready
to actually fight every single actor
that is imposing more struggle upon your
world because struggling itself is a
very abstract notion what exactly
constitutes struggle sir Glee doesn't
commence organically it manifests itself
by an interaction and conflict with
entities that don't share the same
interests needs and belief systems every
goal you have every process you try to
put in place every dream you want to
materialize is susceptible to hurdles
and unpredictable events the world feels
like a huge battlefield and you need to
be ready not just to fight but to fight
the right battles it is a fundamental
principle of retic warfare that its
strategist needs to know their strengths
and weaknesses in order to understand
their capacity to win but winning is not
just related to fighting but also
knowing when to fight and whom to fight
when people embark on endeavours
nowadays most of the time they do so
without properly evaluating their
strategy they ask the question what
should I do with my life and they
haven't even taken baby steps towards
cultivating more self-awareness and
realizing what they're actually capable
of I know people that want elusive
things and keep fantasizing about them
week after week month after month year
after year yet nothing happens when you
create fantasies about future events in
your life that keep remaining fantasies
you start to lose touch with reality and
you just bolster the delusional aspect
of your world when I meet such people
identity we ask them have you prepared
for the battles that you have to face
the look on their face resembles an
elegant mixture of confusion and
preparedness and sometimes even
embarrassment then I become more adamant
and I tell them don't ask me what should
I do with my life just pick your bodies
and pick them wisely
the French philosopher Alain Badiou
introduced back in 1988 in his Magnus
opus being an event the philosophical
notion of the term event according to
but you an event is an unpredictable
break in our everyday worlds that opens
new possibilities
what an event does is that it serves as
a rapture in being through which the
individual finds realization
reconciliation with truth in order
however for this rapture to manifest
itself and have an impact on the
constitution of the individual being
there is not enough the individual needs
to achieve oneness with the event itself
this philosophy accounts for all sorts
of events but the way I interpret it is
that it serves as an illusion to depth
and slowness famous physicist and
philosopher Richard Feynman used to say
that everything can become interesting
if you go into it deeply enough that
kind of thinking and way of life can
emerge organically in the fast paced
world we have created it requires taking
a step back and realizing that the only
way to enact control over the processes
that we decide to internalize is to slow
down and take our time even if the whole
world tells us otherwise through
slowness and depth emerges a new way of
being one where the notion of time and
experiences re-engineered through the
prism of meticulous introspection and
observation of our existence not
necessarily one that leads to over
analysis and results in further
paralysis but one where slow thought
creates its own time and space and heads
is the individual from most calamities
that mindless living can beget with
slowness and depth one can be always
ready and use whatever tools are in
place at any given time Italians have a
nice name for this around Jersey meaning
making do or getting by it is the art of
improvisation a way of using the
resources at hand
to force solutions with such a mindset
you no longer need to ask what should I
do with my life you're just ready to
quote unquote do whatever life throws at
you
life can be difficult I know but how
often do we ponder our responsibility in
the hardships that we encounter how
often do we just pause and reflect on
what is our role in how serendipity
enforces happenstance is upon our
experience we can just float aimlessly
and expect life to make sense that's why
we sometimes need rules even just two
rules for life can make a big difference
hey guys hope you enjoy today's video if
you did make sure to LIKE subscribe turn
on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it if you want to
watch more videos from my channel check
out this one and this one take care see
you soon head here now
[Music]